people are asking what is your morning
routine that gives you such energy I
wake up
it's the first thing I do every morning
I wake up third and what's been
happening prior to my waking up is a
whole unconscious thing that whole
unconscious thing creates thoughts
questions sentences paragraphs insights
and I start writing all those down and
the new day begins so I'm suggesting the
most exquisite time in anybody's life is
just before you wake up and just before
you wake up you woke up and all of that
is present they're really really right
there early early in the morning and so
the question then becomes so how do you
capture that you just allow it to go
down on a piece of paper you allow it to
go down in an email you loud go down in
a notepad and whatever whatever you just
you just get it down start your day in a
completely unique way from the
unconscious to the conscious and the
bridge between those two is astonishing
I'm always astonished with what comes to
mind it's like where did that come from
where did that come from where did that
come from where did that come from it
happens every morning so you get you get
a new idea from the morning through then
act on it do you write it down do you
write it down it always relates to
something I'm doing it always relates to
something I'm working on it always
relates to something that's present if
it's relating to something that's not
present mm-hmm I put
down typically in an email to myself so
I email my colleague herbart subject
data that it added a note note note note
note note and there it sits and I flag
it and then I go back to review it now
what's also true about that is I don't
know if you familiar with the dreaming
room monologues ever are you familiar
with them a little bit but let me tell
you for the audience to to have an
expert about your audience is now
invited to subscribe to Michael Gerber's
dreaming room monologues
and all they have to do is to go to our
website Michael eager bird company's
calm and you'll see a free subscription
just fill it in your name your email
address and every week every Wednesday
afternoon you will receive a new
dreaming room monologue for the rest of
my life those monologues come to me like
that and so the monologues are simply
written and recorded by me and you open
them up every Wednesday and they're all
about inspiration imagination creativity
living in the space unlike the space you
currently live in discovering something
you never discovered before bla bla bla
bla the stuff we're talking about it's a
free it's a gift and that's all they
have to do those monologues to come to
me just like that
so also I'm suggesting your best ideas
come to you just like that so what have
you were to sit down and write those
best ideas just like that every day and
created a form for them the form I
created for them is called the dreaming
room monologues
and welcome to the dreaming room every
single one of you get to do that from
now on at absolutely no cost all you
have to do is click on and boom it's
done